ومن بيروت ضمه الينا الان الخبير العسكريه
واستراتيجيه ناجيه ملاعب اهلا بك
كيف نفهم هذه الخطوه الروسيه وايضا هذا
الحذر الاوكراني في المقابل
يعني اذا تكلمنا بشكل العسكري يعني فقط
كعسكليا عندما ااه جرى تغيير في القياده
الروسيه في في
اوكرانيا اعتمد الرئيس الجديد للقياده
الروسيه اخلاء منطقه غربي نهر الدانبار في
مدينه خرسان عمليه
اخلاء المدنيين واستجاب وزير الدفاع للطلب
الروسي طلب القياده العسكريه الروسيه في
في اوكرانيا في اخلاء المدينه
لحد نهر الدانبل لان البقاء عندما يصبح
البقاء في هذه المدينه الاحتفاظ بها مكلفا
والافضل تركها وان تكون تحت نيران القوات
الروسيه افضل بكثير من التواجد فيها
عرضتان للقذف الاوكراني والهجمات
الكثيفه التي قررت في جنوبيه البلاد
هناك همم حاجز يعني مقطع ارضي هو النهر
اذا ما كان هذا النهر فاصلا حركه ارضيه
بين المدينهتين ممكن الدفاع عن هذه
المدينه من الضفه الاخرى يعني هذه المدينه
تصبح ارض محروقه لان الروس لن لن ينسحب
منها ولن يمكن الاكرام من دخول اليها لذلك
هذه المدينه مصيرها انها ستصبح ارضا
محروقه من قبل الفريقين اللي هو القران
سوف يقصفونها للتقدم والروس زرعوا فيها
اكيد بيكون زرعوا فيها لانه تراجع القتال
التراجعي ي- ي- ي- يجبرهم على تلغيم كل
الاماكن التي صالحه للتلغيم من ابنيه او
اسلحه او او اليات متروكه في المكان لم
يستطيع وسحبها لذلك ستكون هذه المنطقه همم
منطقه حرب قويه سيطره عليها لن يكون الا
عبر الارض المحروق
ونقرؤوس يحضرون ايضا الى هجوم مضاد يعني
في تكتيك العسكريه هل ممكن ان ااه خصام
وان كيف تقول انها غير متاكده من هذا
الانسحاب يتم بالفعل ان تكون تحاول
الايحاء بانها انسحبت وعندما يتقدم الجيش
الاوكراني تقوم بالفعل معركه اعاده
السيطره على خير سنه
لن يخلو همم لن يتركوا خرسان للجيش
الاوكراني بشكل كامل تركوا هذه المنطقه
حتى تصبح منطقه دمار يعني بافلزون منطقه
مدمره كليه اذا ما كان همم يوجد ما زال
يوجد عسكر هم سيخسرون عسكرهم في هذه
المنطقه لان الهجمات الاوكرانيه همم يعني
الدروس بشكل هناك كثافه بالجيش الاوكراني
بالعتاد
بالعتاد الحديثه والصواريخ الحديثه التي
تمكنهم من التقدم اذا ما همم كما حصل في
خير كيف يعني ليستطيعون اذا ما وضعه جهدا
في مكان ما التقدم وهذا اثبت همم على
الارض في همم
صحته على الارض ممكن يتقدم ولكن سيكون
الدمار كثيفا وستكون خسائر كثيره على
الاوكرانيين اذا نتقدموا في هذه المنطقه
وليس على الروس لانهم لان الروس الى خارج
الانسحاب هو اكيد وهو معلن من قبل القياده
العسكريه ومن قبل وزير الدفاع وكذلك جاري
اخلاء المدنيين قبل هذا الانسحاب وهذا
الاخلاق المدنيين كان يثير الكثير من
التساؤلات حول امكانيات استخدام روسيا
للسلاح النووي تكتيكي في المنطقه ما دفعها
لاخلاء هذا المدنيين هل هذا السيناريو ما
زال واريدان مع انسحاب الجيش الروسي هل
يتاكد همم اكثر ام العكس
يعني همم تعرض الروس لان كاسات همم كبيره
همم قبل هذا القرار الروسي المفاجئ مثلا
جسر جسر القرم عندما هدم مجلس القرم او
عندما جرى اغتيال ابنه مسؤول كبير في
روسيا او عندما فجر همم
يعني لم يلجا الروس لها كذا قرار ما زال
لديهم اسلحه يستطيعون استخدامها وقد راينا
انهم استخدم الصواريخ بعيده الماده
وجاهزون لصواريخ اسكندر ان تستخدم ولديهم
من هذه الصواريخ الكثير والصواريخ فارت
صوتيه يستطيعون فيها ارباج
وقد شاهدنا انهم قدروا على همم اقل من 40%
من همم من الطاقه في في اوكرانيا لذلك
لديهم اسلحه لم تستخدم او يستطيعون
استخدامها قبل النوويه